the u.s government's response to the
crisis is evolving by the hour president
biden spent the weekend meeting with his
national security team and consulting
with allies and he is also
working on his first state of the union
address scheduled for tomorrow night ed
o'keefe is with the president in
wilmington delaware ed good morning
tony good morning the president's yet to
hold another meeting with allies to work
on that coordinated response and as he
puts the finishing touches on his state
of the union address aide's now warned
that it's likely going to focus a bit
more than expected on world events
president biden faces a series of
daunting challenges as he prepares to
give his first formal state of the union
address the pandemic a supreme court
confirmation fight a stalled legislative
agenda
and then there's the crisis in ukraine
the biden administration swiftly
condemned vladimir putin's decision to
put russian nuclear deterrence forces on
special alert president putin is
continuing to escalate this war in a
manner that is totally unacceptable
and we have to continue to condemn his
actions in the most
strong the strongest possible way the
president is joining forces with
european allies by kicking most russian
banks out of swift an international
banking messaging system that makes
global transactions easier
new sanctions will also target russia's
central bank and allies are beginning to
target russian oligarchs with ties to
putin who shield his wealth in offshore
accounts i love this because it's
personal
vladimir putin has shown what he is he's
a thug he's a despot some republicans
want the administration to also target
russia's energy sector i'd like to see
the oil industry
affected it's time for the president and
some of our european partners to quit
[ __ ] footing around the white house is
reluctant to do so at least for now we
also want to do that and make sure we're
minimizing the impact on the global
marketplace and do it in a united way
also this week mr biden's supreme court
nominee katanji brown jackson is
scheduled to begin meeting with senators
as democrats hope to have her confirmed
by easter hopefully with gop votes it is
in the best interest not only of the
supreme court but of the united states
senate for this to be bipartisan
so it's not yet clear if the president
plans to introduce something new
regarding his domestic agenda maybe
something on climate change reviving
that child tax credit since aides say
it's foreign policy that is now
dominating so much of his time
tony but there is a big u.n report out
today as well we're going to talk about
that later ed thank you very much